il y a un truc qui vous est peut-être
déjà arrivé vous êtes allongé ou même
vous êtes juste assis vous vous levez
d'un coup et là vous avez la tête qui
tourne vous sentez pas bien vous
commencez à avoir des étoiles etc et bah
ça ça s'appelle de l'hypotension
orthostatique oui le nom est un petit
peu flippant mais en fait ça va en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que quand vous
vous levez d'un coup comme ça il y a
beaucoup de sang qui descend dans vos
jambes votre corps il essaye de
s'adapter mais vous faites une chute de
tension et quand la tension baisse comme
ça surtout quand elle baise rapidement
bah ça donne ce genre de malaise qui
peut aller jusqu'à la perte de
connaissance dans l'absolu c'est pas
méchant mais si vous savez que vous avez
tendance à faire ça c'est bien de
prendre son temps quand vous vous levez
et d'attendre un petit peu avant de
commencer à vous déplacer histoire de
pas tomber si vous perdez connaissance
et de pas vous faire mal et puis si ça
vous arrive souvent bah c'est quand même
pas mal d'essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe en en parlant à votre médecin
pas en cherchant sur Google